اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد التغطيه مستمره
لاخر التطورات الميدانيه في السودان وفي
تطور لافت اعلن الجيش السوداني مقتل مساعد
الملحق العسكري المصري بالخرطوم باستهداف
سيارته على الطريق العام واتهم الجيش
السوداني قوات الدعم السريع بالهجوم مشيرا
الى ان تلك القوات تستهدف البعثات
الدبلوماسيه والمداريه
[موسيقى]
تحركنا من منطقه الخرطوم الى منطقه على
بعد حوالي 1200 1300 كيلو
صعب انك تخرج من بيتك
نقطه يعني
الوضع كتير تحت القصف كان يعني خلص كنا
متحضرين حاله ان الموت يعني باي لحظه
كل ما تتواصل الشباكات في محيطه القياده
العامه ومطار الخرطوم دعا الامين العام
للامم المتحده جميع الاطراف السودان لوقف
العنف وخفض التصعيد وعدم استهداف المدنيين
والعوده طبعا الى طاوله المفاوضات
منذ بدايه القتال في الخامس عشر من ابريل
قتل مئات الاشخاص واجرح الالاف يجب وقف
العنف والذي يهددو بمساه في المنطقه كلها
ادين القصف على مناطق المدنيين وادعو جميع
الاطراف لوقف العمليات في المناطق
المسكونه انا على اتصال مع اطراف الصراع
وادعوهم لخفض التصعيد والعوده لطواله
الحوار
هذا وتسارعت مشاهدينا عمليات اجلاء
الرعايه والدبلوماسيين الاجانب من السودان
وهناك مخاوف لدى السودانيين تتزايد من طول
امد هذه الحرب
دول العالم تسابق الزمن لاجلاء رعاياها في
السودان في وقت تتواصل فيه المعارك
الداميه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع لكن
امال السودانيين في انهاء الحرب تتقلص
ويتسع حجم المخاوف من طول امد الحرب
تقديرات محليه ودوليه اعتبرت ان هذه
العمليات دلاله واضحه الى موجه عنف مقبله
وهو ما يراه السودانيون دليلا على غياب
افق الحل السياسي في البلاد واستمرار
النزاع الدائري ليصل امتداده الى الاحياء
السكنيه
رساله المجتمع الدولي واحده وقف الحرب
واسكات المدافع والبدء في الحوار والبحث
عن الحل السياسي لانه لا يوجد حل عسكري
لهذه الحرب وهذا ما نقوم به من خلال اخراج
مواطنين لست مضطرا للشرح ما يحدث هناك
تراه انت تشاهد التلفاز لذلك يجب ان يخرج
ومن المستحيل الاستمرار في العمل
كدبلوماسي لذا فان افضل شيء تفعله معهم هو
اخراجهم
اصوات اطلاق الرصاص ودوي الانفجارات يطغى
على دعوات التهدئه ويزيد من تعقيد عمليات
اجلاء الرعايه المحاصرين بين الجانبين
المتحاربين رغم تعهدات دوليه واقليميه
باسكات البنادق والتوصل الى تسويه سياسيه
سلطان العيبان العربيه
وبينما تستمر عمليات اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من السودان مع استمرار المواجهات
قال اللواء بحري ركن صالح بابكر قائد
الفرقه 101 مشاه في البحريه السودانيه
للعربيه ان هناك تسهيلات للاجراءات
واجراءات دخول سفن اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
فلنستمع لمقاله حاولنا نسهل كل الاجراءات
المتعلقه
بالمواني بدخول السفن
ورباطه وايضا بوصول الرعايه هنا وتجميعهم
وضيافتهم وما الى ذلك من من نجرات حقيقه
كانت عمليات الاجلاء يعني مشهد بالطريقه
سلسه جدا
سهل كل الاجراءات حتى الاجراءات الرسميه
للجوازات
والجمارك كانت في مكان استقبال هذه
الجاليات الان احنا بصدد عندنا الان بتحمل
ثلاثه سفن اللي هي سفن من المملكه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعندنا سفينه هنديه
وعندنا سفينه كوريه جنوبيه وفي انتظار عدد
اخر من السفن حقيقه
مشاهدينا سانتقل الى الصحافه عبد القادر
بكاش عبد القادر سابدا من يعني تطورات
الاخيره الان عمليات الاجلاء التي تتم عبر
بورد سودان
ما هي اخر
تحديثاتها وعن ماذا نتحدث عن السفن
الموجوده هناك الجنسيات التي يتم نقله
بهذه الاثناء
بواسطه ثلاثه سفن منها سفن مدنيه وسفن
حربيه عرفت بالميناء الان سفينه مصريه
تطبع لشركه مصريه اسمها ن
وهي السفينه ملكيه ورثت ايضا سفينه هنديه
بارجه عسكريه قطع حربيه رصد في الميناء
الاخضر وايضا هناك بارجات سعوديه وبارج
امريكيه في طريقها للسودان ومتوقع الى كل
الرعايه الدول وموظفي المنظمات الرومانيه
الذين وصلوا مدينه
حوالي سنه الف موظف اممي
وباء دبلوماسيه الان يوجدون
اين اين تم يعني وضعهم
بهذه الاثناء الى حين تامين اجلاء عبر هذه
السفن تابعه اللوائيه داخل المدينه غير
مهيئه لاستقبال عادات كبيره بهذا الهجمه
في مدينه بورسلان لكن بصوره عامه الان
الفنادق الرئيسيه بالمدينه والشقق
الفندقيه اصلا هذه مدينه سياحيه كانت بها
فندقيه كبيره
خلال الفتره الماضيه كانت تلتزمها
مهرجانات سياحيه وكذلك عدد من الانشطه
السياحيه ومما دفع المواطنين للاستثمار في
مجال السياحي لكن هذه الاسماء المدينه
تشهد توافد غير مسبوقه من البيتات
الدبلوماتيه من موظفي
المنظمات
الانسانيه وكذلك من السودانيين الذين
يفيدون باعتبار ان هذه المدينه ام المدينه
الان في السودان وتقع على الساحل السوداني
وتبعد من الخرطوم حوالي 300 الى 850 كيلو
متر لذلك
التفويس كبير جدا هذه المدينه التي تبعد
حوالي 900 كلم عن العاصمه الوصول اليها
يستغرق حوالي الاربعه عشره ساعه ولكن مع
المجموعات الكبيره مع نقاط التفتيش مع
عمليات القذف التي تحصل الطريق تستغرق
بحسب التقارير الاخيره حوالي 20 ساعه هل
رصدتم يعني من الذين وصلوا الى هناك
الصعوبات التي واجهوها خلال هذا المسار
هناك شعوبات بتبيعه السفر لكن ليست هناك
اي مهددات امنيه بحمد الله الطريق في
المسافه من نهر النيل من منطقه الى مدينه
بورسودان عام من تماما شغل السودان الان
خالي تماما من الدعم السليم والغواطن
المسله هي التي تسيطر وهي التي تتبنى
عمليه اجراء الرعايه وعمليه تامين الطريق
وهناك مجهودات مغذره تقوم بها القوات
المسلحه السودانيه في التفويج هذه البعثات
والموظفين الاماميين وفي تعميم الطريق
والان حتى الان ليست هناك اي اعتداءات
باستثناء اعتداء تم اليوم لمساعده
المرهق العسكري المصري في السودان لكن
يعني الان الطريق امن
في المسافه من جنبي الى بورس حوالي 700
كيلو الى يعني 680 كيلو تقريبا كلها الان
امنه تماما ولكن
اسمح لي حتى التقارير الغربيه لا يعني لا
تقول بان الطرق امن نهائيا وهيا تدرس
كيفيه تامين نقاط على هذا الطريق لتامين
سلام وامانه عبور المواطنين ان كان الذين
يحملون جنسيات مزدوجه وان كان المواطنين
من جنسيات اخرى غير الامريكيه والاوروبيه
وبالتالي هناك خوف لان ايضا قوات الدعم
السريع ايضا لديها خوف من استقدام قوات
اضافيه عبر هذه الطريق للجيش السوداني
الطرق الان الطريق امن تماما لكن من حق
البعثات والدبلوماسيين الاجانب ان يتخوفوا
في ظل
النزاع المصلى الذي تشربه العاصمه منهقهم
ان يخافوا من الطريق لكن الطريق الان في
ولايه البحر الاحمر وفي ولايه نهر النيل
ايضا في الطريق ايضا هناك طريقه اخر هو
الطريق البديل طريق مدني القضارف كسلان
ايضا تريك يمر من الاتجاه الشرق واذا
الفريق امن جدا بحمد الله حتى الان لم
تشهد هذه الطرق اي اعتداءات لها
دبلوماسيين ولا على منظمات
والطرق عامه تماما الحمد لله هو الهجره
عمليه
الاجلاء تتم بشكل سلس حتى الان هناك اجلاء
يتم بالتعائرات عسكريه عبر مطار بورسودان
وهناك اجلاء يتم عبر الموانئ البحريه
وايضا من الاشياء المزعجه جدا هناك عدد
كبير
جدا الانسانيه
من السودان وهذا الفريق طبعا فراغ في
الجانب الانساني لذلك
طبعا موظفيها وبعثات الموجوده هناك شكرا
لك الصحافه عبد القادر بكاش حدثنا من
بورسودان
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى اعلان الجيش
السوداني مقتل مساعد الملحق العسكري
المصري بالخرطوم من القاهره ينضم الينا
الدكتور احمد الشحات مستشار الامن
الاقليمي والدولي دكتور احمد يعني نحن
نتحدث عن تطور طبعا ينذر بامثلات امني
داخل السودان وهو مكانه تتخوفه مصر ما
تتخوفه كل دول منطقه وحتى دول العالم ماذا
يعني هذا الحادث وكيف ستتعاطى القاهره معه
اولا اذا تاكد هذا الخبر بشكل كامل
فانا اعرب عن عزائي وعزاء الشعب المصري
كله في هذا الخبر والحادثه الاليم
واتمنى ان يكون في مراجعه للخبر يعني لان
خبر فعلا محزن
ولا بد ان يتحمل مسؤوليته كل من يقع في
السودان سواء طرفي الصراع العسكري ولان
البعثه الدبلوماسيه لها حصانه خاصه تبقى
من كافه الاتفاقيات والدوليه يعني فكن انه
يستهدف احد اعضاء البعثه الدبلوماسيه بهذا
الشكل فلابد ان نحمل المسؤوليه
للمسؤول عن التامين له وهو الجيش السوداني
ونحمل ايضا الطرف الاخر الذي يتحرك
بعشوائيه اذا فرضت اذا اذا ما كانش فيه
قصد من الاستهداف وللاسف هذا الموضوع
هيفرض ده تطور حاد جدا
اسمح لي ان اشير الى اننا يعني هذا الخبر
هو نقل عن الجيش السوداني الذي اكد هذا
الخبر ولكن التاكيد الرسمي المصري لم يعلن
بعد نحن بانتظاره ولكن في حال ثبت ان هذا
الموضوع هو استهداف متعمد ماذا يعني
لابد ان يكون طبعا الدوله المصريه من
ثوابتها حمايه الرعايه خارج الدوله يعني
في كافه الدول واكيد الدوله عندها من الرد
الموضوعي والحاسم اللي يتفق مع حجم حجم
الازمه او مع تحديد المسؤوليه المسؤوليه
داخل السودان عن ماذا حدث سواء بقى على
المسارات السياسيه على المسارات الاخرى
الذي لا اعرف مداها الخبر عاجل وما زال
يعني في اطار البحث وتقديرات الموقف
المختلفه اللي انت بتتخذها الدوله المصريه
ولكن الذي اؤكد عليه ان اتوقع ان يكون في
رد فاعل يمكن يكون اكثر فاعليه دكتور احمد
وهناك اتجاه نعم اتفضل يا فندم وهناك في
اتجاه لوجستي سيكون متسارع جدا فيه
واتوقع ان كافه الدول ستسارع في تصارع
وتيره
واخلاء عمليات الاخلاق طبعا بناء على هذا
الخبر يعني بعمليات الاجتماعي هناك جاليه
مصريه كبيره موجوده داخل الخرطوم ان كان
من دبلوماسيين ورسميين ان كاننا من
مواطنين ان كان من تلامذه يعني نتحدث عن
عدد كبير طبعا عمليه الاجلاء من الخرطوم
الى القاهره تتم برا كان هناك تنسيق بين
اللجنه التي استحدثتها
السلطات المصريه وبين الجيش السوداني
لتامين ممرات من اماكن النزاع ومن الاماكن
العاديه نحو القاهره هل يعني هذه العمليه
ستكون اسرع الان وتيره بالساعات المقبله
طبيعي طبيعي جدا سيكون لها
اجراءات متسارعه بشكل واسع جدا وسيكون لها
تامين خاص وان تدخلت القوات المصريه فهذا
في في حمايه هذا التامين وهي قادره على
ذلك لان الرعايه هناك زي ما حضرتك قلت
كثيرين وهناك حدود واسعه ما بين الطرفين
تتعدى 1200 كيلو فانا اتوقع ان الدوله
المصريه هتقوم بدورها وده مش جديد عملناه
قبل كده في ليبيا واخلنا 2 مليون فرد يعني
فاتوقع انه يكون في تسارع في هذا الاتجاه
بشكل كبير تحت رعايه الدوله المصريه
وبالتعاون مع السلطه الشرعيه في السودان
الشقي
يعني هناك مخاوف عديده اليوم لدى السلطات
المصريه لان الملف السوداني طبعا كما
الملف الليبي هو معقد وشائك بالنسبه
للداخل المصري ان كان من موضوع الارهاب
وجماعات الارهابيه من ملف النيل والعلاقه
مع مع اثيوبيا وغيرها كل هذه الملفات
المتداخله المتشابكه التي تجعل من الملف
السوداني اولويه بالنسبه لمصر كيف يمكن ان
تؤثر على الحركه الدبلوماسيه المصريه وعلى
يعني المبادرات التي ترعاها مصر
اولا زي ما حضرتك قلت مصر للاسف الشديد
حاليا محيطه بكثير من بقر التوتر في كافه
حدودها سواء الغربيه اتجاه ليبيا
والجنوبيه اتجاه السودان وطبعا القضيه
الفلسطينيه ومشاكلها اتجاه اتجاه الشمال
الشرقي ولكن الدبلوماسيه المصريه هي
بتتحرك في اتجاهات متوازنه تتوافق مع
المقاومات السياسيه اللي بتسال عليها
الدوره المصريه سواء في اهدافها وفي
الياتها انما يعني لن يتراجع الدور المصري
في دعم العمليه السياسيه او عمليه الوصول
الى حل توافقي في الداخل السوداني فده شيء
في تاريخ الدبلوماسيه المصريه معروف وده
وتدخلنا في اصعب المشاكل في المنطقه
العربيه بالكامل والسودان اتجاه استراتيجي
جنوبي لمصر هام وعمقها كل مهم وحضرتك ذكرت
ان في ملفات مشتركه كثيره غير العمق
التاريخي والعلاقات التاريخيه فلن تتراجع
بهذه الحوادث او
المواقف دكتور طبعا فلن تتراجع الدوله
المصريه عن موقفها الداعم شكرا لك يا
دكتور احمد شحات مستشار الامن القومي
والدولي حدثنا من القاهره
اذا مشاهدينا ايضا ينضم الينا من لندن عبر
سكايب الدكتور ابراهيم مخير رئيس الشؤون
الخارجيه بالمكتب الاستشاري لقائد قوات
الدعم السريع سابدا معك دكتور من موضوع
الاستهداف الذي طال الملحق العسكري المصري
والذي يعني اتهم مساعد طبعا الملحق
العسكري المصري والذي اتهم فيها الجيش
ببيانه قوات الدعم السريع باستهدافه على
الطريق السريع كيف تردون على هذه النقطه
وهل من معطيات عليها
اولا شكرا لتسليط الضوء
القديم انا لا املك اي معلومات عن هذا
الحدث الذي انصحها فهو حدث مؤلم
ونعزي فيه الشعب المصري جميعه والحكومه
المصريه لكن اود ان اوضح شيء اولا نحن
قوات قواتنا
تسيطر على العاصمه من الداخل اي هو
منافذها ولكن لا تسيطر على الطرق السريعه
الخليه العاصمه هذه المناطق يسيطر عليها
الجيش السوداني
بما ان الجيش قد اعلن هذا فربما قد يكون
الرجل قد سقط في تلك الاماكن اود ان اؤكد
اننا ولكن اذا كان جيش السوداني يسيطر على
هذه الطرقات والجيش السوداني على تنسيق
كامل على مستوى الرسمي وعلى مستوى
القيادات العليا مع الجيش المصري ومع
الجهات المصريه لماذا سيقوم هو باستهداف
المساعد ام ممكن ان يكون هناك طرف ثالث
ونفس السؤال
لماذا علينا ان نستهدفه ونستعدي قوه اخرى
ونحن موجودين داخل العاصمه انا اود ان
اوضح شيء
القضيه
نحن نتهم الجيش السوداني بانه قد استولد
عليه المجموعات اسلاميه متطرفه
دكتور ابراهيم ايضا الجيش السوداني هنا
يتهمكم بانكم تقومون يعني انتم تقومون
بعمليات استهداف عشوائيه وبان قواتكم غير
منضبطه على الارض
من قبل كنت اودي ان اذكر ان حسني مبارك قد
تعرض لعمليه اغتيال من قبل نفسي اولئك
الذين الان هم موجودين في الجيش السوداني
ولكن نحن قواتنا قوات نظاميه تم تشريعها
بالبرلمان وتم تدريبها بخبرات سودانيه
وغير سودانيين تستهد وكانت التدريبات
تستهدف مكافحه ذات تهريب البشر والاسلحه
عبر الصحراء وقد ابلت فيها بلاء حسن
ومقاومه الفتن القبليه وغيره الان نحن
موجودين داخل العاصمه وقمنا بخطوات لتجنب
يعني تجنب زياده الكارت السوداني اولا يجب
ان نؤكد اننا دائما مستجبنا لكل هدنه عيني
اليها ولكن تم اختراقها من قبل الجيش ومن
هنا نعتقد انه يجب على المجتمع الدولي غير
حسن الجيش على الحفاظات الهدنه ووقفه
كامله لاطلاق النار اعتقد ان عليه اولا
ارسال مراقبين دولين ثم فرض حظر كامل
للطيران في الخرطوم اليوم نحن نتحدث عن
اجلاء لكافه الدبلوماسيين اي حتى يعني كان
هناك سؤال للمتحدث باسم البيت الابيض يعني
رفضوا الحديث عن ارسال اي اي قوات حفظ
سلام او اي احد الى الخرطوم الان بسبب
يعني هذا الانفلات الامني الذي بدات
التقارير تتحدث عنه وهو يتجلى الان بما
حدث لمساعد الملحقه العسكري اليوم يعني
حاله الانفلات الموجوده في الشارع انتم
متهمين فيها وانتم تتهمون الجيش وبالتالي
هذا لن يؤمن او لن يسمح بارسال اي احد الى
داخل الخرطوم لا بل انسحاب تام من الخرطوم
كما ترين كما تعرفين ان السجون قد فتحت
لجميع المتطرفين
والذين كانوا ينتمون الى التنظيمات
الاسلاميه المختلفه ولكن نحن من جانبنا
اولا لا نمنع اي مواطن من الخروج من
العاصمه وكذلك امنا جميع الدبلوماسيين لم
لم يصاب اي دبلوماسي في اثناء خروجه
وعبوره عبر مناقدي القناه التي نرتكز
عليها
وكنا قادرين اذا عشينا ان نفعل ذلك
ثم ولكن ترين بنفسك ان الحجمات التي تاتي
من الجيش اسمح لي انت موجود في لندن
وبالتالي بعيد جدا عن العاصمه السودانيه
ممكن ان تكون تنقل لنا بعض الاخبار او بعض
التطورات التي ترد لك من هناك ولكن ما
الذي يؤكد ان ما يحصل على الارض هو طبق
الاصل عما تتحدث عنه
اولا انا موجود في لندن بصفه مسؤول عن
الشؤون الخارجيه وللاسف بدت
الجيش هجم على قوات الدعم السريع وانا
موجود هنا
ولكن كل كل التطورات التي تحدث على الارض
تصلني واغلبها انا انشرها في صوره
فيديوهات ورسائل كما نخاطب الانسانيين
والمنظمات المختلفه
بدعمنا ودعم السودانيين عموما
واخرها نحن نقوم بحمله بحمله يعني مشارك
في حمله منها لا للحرب
نشارك في حمله للتصدي
دكتور الى ان اشير الى هذا العاجل الذي
يرد الان البنتاغون يقول بان اي تدخل
خارجي في السودان سيفاقم الازمه هناك طبعا
هذا التصريح بعد كل التقارير التي تحدث عن
تدخلات خارجيه واحتمال مد سلاح الى الداخل
السوداني لايطال امد هذه الازمه شكرا لك
دكتور ابراهيم مخير رئيس الشؤون الخارجيه
للدعم السريع حدثتنا بلندن
بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان مع نظيره الاماراتي عبد الله بن
زايد جهود وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
وزير الخارجيه الاماراتيه تمنى دور
المملكه في عمليه اجلاء رعايه الامارات
والعديد من دول العالم من السودان الى
السعوديه مشيدا بجهود البارزه التي تقوم
بها السعوديه بتنفيذ عمليه الاجلاء
بالتعاون مع مختلف البلاد
قال السفير السعودي في الخرطوم بان علي بن
حسن جعفر قال في مقابله مع العربيه ان
عمليات اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب في السودان
مستمره واشار الى ان المملكه ساعدت باجلاء
رعايه دول عده فلنستمع الى مقاله
قبل ان استمع مشاهدينا سانتقل الى صور
مباشره من روما حيث حطت طائره اجلاء كانت
تقل على متنها مواطنين
ودبلوماسيين ورسميين كانوا موجودين في
السودان طبعا هذه الطائره حطت هناك بعدما
تم اجلاء هؤلاء من العاصمه الخرطوم الى
ميناء بورتسودان ومنها طبعا الى روما
للتفكير مشاهدينا دول اوروبيه عده قامت
باجلاء مواطنيها اجلاء جوي فرنسا بريطانيا
ايطاليا وايضا عدد اخر من الدول الاوروبيه
اجلت مواطنيها بعمليات اجلاء جويه من
السودان الى مسقط راسه وبعض هؤلاء ايضا
كان قد وصل الى مطار جده ومن هناك تم
اجلاؤهم ايضا الى دولهم
اذا مسؤولين رسميين ايطاليين او وفط يعني
موجودين هناك لاستقبال هذه الطائره
واستقبال المواطنين الذين تم اجلائهم من
السودان بعد التطورات الاخيره والاشتباكات
التي حصلت
عمليه الاجلاء هذه يعني
ايضا كان هناك بموازاتها عمليات اجلاء
دوليه لجميع الرعايه ومعظم الرعايه
الموجودين داخل السودان المرحله الاولى
التي نتحدث عنها هنا هي مرحله اجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه والرسميه والعاملين
في السفارات وفي المنظمات الدوليه
والاماميه طبعا هناك مرحله ثانيه هي مرحله
اجلاء المواطنين التي بدات من قبل الجانب
المصري وبدات ايضا من قبل الدول العربيه
ان كان المملكه العربيه السعوديه وقطر
كويت كل الجاليات العربيه التي موجوده
كانت يعني موجوده داخل الخرطوم
اذا هبطت الطائره كما نشاهد بهذه الصور
ووصلت الى مطار روما وهي
تقل رعايه تم اجلائهم من السودان
[موسيقى]
عمليات الاجلاء هذه تم اتخاذ القرار بها
بعد بعدما تعرضت يعني عدد من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه من المقر الرسميه لعمليه قصف
عشوائيه تبادل الطرفين الجيش الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع التهم فيها ايضا
تتزامن مع رفض واستحاله يعني حتى الساعه
ان يكون هناك مسار سلمي ومسار
لانهاء هذا الصراع والاشتباك الدائر بين
الطرفين والمستمر حتى الساعه في داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم وفي مناطق في الاطراف
اذا الطائره العسكريه الايطاليه حطت في
مطار روما
ونتابع مشاهدينا اذا قبل ان اكمل ساشير
الى هذا العاجل مصادر العربيه تم في بيان
الجيش السوداني حول مقتل مساعد الملحق
العسكري المصري في السودان اذا كانت هذا
التحديث الاخير حول
البيان الذي اصدره الجيش السوداني عن مقتل
مساعد الملحق العسكري المصري في السودان
واتهام قوات الدعم السريع
باستهداف السياره التابعه له على الطريق
السريع
اذا اعود مشاهدينا الى هذه الصوره
المباشره
الذي التي نتابعها على الهواء مباشره
لوصول طائره عسكريه ايطاليه الى مطار روما
والتي تقل على متنها عدد من الدبلوماسيين
ومن المواطنين والرعايه الذين تم نقلهم من
العاصمه الخرطوم الى ميناء بورسودان وصولا
الى روما
نستمع مشاهدينا الى مقاله سفير مصر
بالخرطوم والذي ينفي الصفير السعودي في
الخرطوم واعود
بالصفه التامه اجلاء الرعايه
السعوديين
والرعايه الدول الخليج بسفرائهم منذ ثلاثه
ايام وصلوا بحمد الله الى
المملكه بيسر وسلامه
ولكن هناك بعض السعوديين الذين يتواصلون
معنا ولم نكن على علم بهم وهم في عدد من
الولايات السودانيه ونتخذ الاجراءات
اللازمه في ترحيلهم منذ ان عرفنا
بمقرات تواجدهم وعديد منهم قادر امس
بالليل
واما عمليه الاجلاب بصفه عامه فهي مستمره
لكل
الرعايه الاجانب
الذين طلبت دولهم ان
تقوم المملكه بمساعدتهم بالاجلاء والوصول
الى مدينه جده ما هي ابرز الدول التي
انطلبت ان تنسق معها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه حتى تدلي بحكم
الامكانيات بحكم القرب ما هي ابرز هذه
الدول
حقيقه معظم الدول
غربيه وعربيه واسيويه
فمثلا
رجلين الرعايه امريكان بريطانيين
ايرلنديين
وغيرهم ثم
وصلت الرغبات من
المغرب وتونس وموريتانيا
والجزائر والباكستان وتايلاند واليابان
وماليزيا وهذا
ورعاياهم البعض منهم وصل واجلناه والبعض
سيتم خلال هذه الليله
والايام القادمه اجلاهم بسلام ان شاء الله
الليله ان شاء الله ستغادر سفينه بحموله
2500 شخص
من مختلف الجلسات نحن
جهزنا على مدار 24 ساعه طاقم سعودي
لاستقبال
وتجهيز وانهاء جوازات الاجراءات الرسميه
للاجلاء
سواء هنا في هذا المقر او
بالتعاون مع اجهزه الشرطه السودانيه
هذه المناسبه اود ان ارفع
ما وصلني من شكر وتقدير
كل سفراء ورعايه الدول التي اجليناها او
الدول المتوقع اجلال رعاياها
للقياده الحكيمه
ولما قدمته المملكه من يسر وتيسير
لاجلاء مواطنيها الى المملكه والتعاون
والتنسيق في داخل المملكه ما بين اللجان
السعوديه الرسميه
المكلفه بالاجراء وسفارات هذه الدول
هل من جهد متوقع للمملكه والرباعيه
الدوليه في تهدئه الاوضاع في السودان اخي
العزيز
الجهود
المجموعه الرباعيه الاليه الثلاثيه لم
تتوقف اللحظه
قبل الاندلاع الاعمال القتاليه وبعدها وما
زلنا
ولعلك تعرف انه كان هناك هدينتين كانت
بسبب
العمل ادوا للمجموعه الرباعيه والاليات
الثلاثيه
ومواطنين سودانيين
وجدوا من
مصلحه الوطن ان يكون هناك
تحديه وان شاء الله ما زال العمل مستمر
للوصول الى وقف الاطلاق النار والعوده الى
الحوار لان الحوار هو الاساس الذي سيحقق
ان شاء الله تطلعات الشعب السوداني في
السودان مستقر وموحد باذن الله طبيعه
الخطوه القادمه
نحن الان في تواصل مع الطرفين
هم من الاول هو ايقاف اطلاق النار بعدك
سنبحث الخطوه التاليه ان شاء الله
مشاهدينا ساعيد واذكر بالعواجل التي ترد
على الشاشه الخارجيه المصريه تنفي البيان
الجيش السوداني حول استهداف ومقتل مساعد
الملحق العسكري المصري في السودان وايضا
سفير مصر بالخرطوم يقول ما اثير حول مقتل
مساعد الملحق العسكري المصري هناك وطبعا
كانت هذه اخر العواجل بعد البيان الذي
اصدره الجيش السوداني عن مقتل مساعد
الملحق العسكري المصري على الطريق السريع
في السودان واتهام لقوات الدعم السريع
بهذا الاستهداف للحديث عن تفاصيل الارض
هناك تنضم الي بالاستوديو مديره مكتب
العربيه في الخرطوم لنا يعقوب لنا اهلا
وسهلا بك سابدا من هذه النقطه موضوع
الطريقه السريعه هل فعلا يسيطر عليها
الجيش السوداني كما تقول قوات الدعم
السريع ام هناك اختراقات
لا يمكن حقيقه ليال للتاكيد على جميع
الطرق طريق بورسودان الخرطوم كان محمي من
قبل الجيش السوداني هذا امر صحيح في اجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه السابقه صحيح ان
عربات الجيش لم تكن موجوده في مقاطع
الفيديو التي انتشرت ولكن كان هناك تنسيق
عبر الخارجيه السودانيه الخارجيه
السودانيه نسقت مع الجيش السوداني لحمايه
وصول البعثات من الخرطوم الى بورسودان حيث
من هناك اما انها تذهب الى جده عبر البحر
او الى القاهره عبر البر فبالتالي حمايه
هذا الطريق كان عبر الجيش ولكن لا يمكن ان
نقول انه امن
لان هناك اشتباكات كانت تحدث في بعض الطرق
الرئيسيه من الولايات السودانيه للخرطوم
ذلك تحسبا من ان هناك قوات من الجيش ستاتي
الى الخرطوف فبالتالي هناك تحسن من قبل
الدعم السريع وتاهب لقوه الدعم وبالتالي
الحديث يعني عن ان هذه الطريق امنه مئه
بالمئه وعمليه الاجلاء من
هي امنه مئه بالمئه هي غير دقيقه غير
دقيقه اذا كانت هذه الطريق غير امنه مئه
بالمئه وعمليات الاجلاء غير مضموضه هناك
يعني بعض التقارير التي بدات تتحدث خصوصا
عن الجانب الامريكي لان لديه رعايه يعني
جاليه كبيره هناك من حاملي الجنسيات
المزدوجه عن استحداث نقاط على هذه الطريق
عن عمليات تنسيق وتحليق للطيران الحربي
وايضا لبارجات حربيه هناك لتامين نقل
هؤلاء هل من السهوله تطبيق على الارض
والتامين مع طرفي النزاع
سؤال مهم جدا وسؤال في الحقيقه الاجابه
عليه صعبه لماذا لان الدعم السريع يقول في
بياناته انه نسق مع بعض الدول لاجلاء
الرعايه والجيش السوداني يصدر بيان ويكذب
فيه الدعم السريع بانه لم يقم بالتنسيق
ولم يقم بالحمايه لكن من المهم هو ما
قالته هذه البعثات الدبلوماسيه هي قالت
انها نسقت مع الطرفين هذا يعني انها
تواصلت مع الدعم السريع وتواصلت مع الجيش
السوداني لتضمن عدم اعتداء اي طرف عليها
اثناء عمليه الاجلاء او اثناء عمليه
التحرك يعني وقبل قليل نحن راينا بيان
للجيش السوداني نفاخه الصفير المصري هذا
يشير ايضا الى ان هناك ربكه وعدم دقه ربما
في
اصدار هل هناك انقسام بالداخل يعني هذا ما
يشير اليه دائما ان كان قوى الحريه
والتغيير وان كان الدعم السريع وغيره الى
ان هناك
ساسميه لوبي داخلي ما وراء البرهان هو
الذي يتحكم بكل ما يحصل لا اعتقد حتى الان
يبدو ان موقف الجيش موقف واحد وواضح ربما
قبل بدء هذه الحرب المواقف للجيش السوداني
كانت
غير واضحه بالنسبه للمواطن العادي
وبالنسبه للقوى السياسيه ما الذي يريده
الجيش هل يريد المضي بالعمليه السياسيه
كما هي ام انه كان يرغب باضافه بعض القوى
السياسيه وينتظر ذلك كما كان هناك في
تصريحات سابقه لينا اليوم بعمليات الاجلاء
طبعا المرحله الاولى كنا نتحدث عن اجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه والرسميين المرحله
الثانيه هي اجلاء المواطنين والرعايه
الموجودين هناك من قبل جامعه الدول بدات
مع مع بعض الدول ولكن هناك اعداد كبيره ما
زالت موجوده البعض اصبح يتحدث عن طرق اخرى
غير ايضا طريق الخرطوم بورتسودان هل هناك
من طرق اخرى امنه لهؤلاء ليخرجوا من
الخرطوم ابدا لا نستطيع الحديث عن طرق
امنه ما لم تعلن الاطراف ذلك لا يوجد طريق
امن الان في السودان يعني الحديث عن ان
هناك طريق امن ليسلكه الناس هذا امر فيه
مخاطره وفي دعايه غير صحيحه لكن هناك طرق
تكون اقل خطوره من الطرق الاخرى هناك طرق
ربما يقل فيها نقاط التفتيش هناك طرق من
المعلوم من هو المسيطر عليها بالتالي قد
تسهل او يسهل للناس معرفه طريقه التعامل
تلك القوه في هذا المكان مع القادمين ومع
المسافرين عمليات اجلاء يعني عائلاتكم
هناك الكثير من الزملاء
يسعون الى اجلاء عائلاتهم ومنهم نجح بذلك
كيف تتم هذه العمليات باي طرق لاخراجهم من
الخرطوم الى اي ماده هم يعانون اليوم يعني
للخروج هناك طبعا هو قرار دائما ما تتخذه
الاسره السودانيه اما بالبقاء في الخرطوم
وتحت هذا القذف اول مغادره وهو يختلف كما
ذكرنا وربما من اسره لاخرى هذا القرار
قرار صعب ليس قرار سهل بان تخرج من
العاصمه لتذهب الى دوله اخرى خاصه يعني ان
كان لديك اقارب واصدقاء فهو ليس قرار
السهل ولكن هذه العمليات التي تتم الان هي
تتم عبر كما ذكرنا قبل قليل عبر الطريق هو
طريق
اما انهم يذهبون الى مدني بولايه الجزيره
وهذا الطريق بحسب ما علمنا من كثير من
الزملاء انه طريق كان هو كانت هناك فيه
نقاط تفتيش كانت هناك فيه بعض انتشار
لعربات الجيش ولكن كان امن في الوصول الى
ولايه الجزيره هناك تامين اقوى واكثر في
الوصول الى ولايه بورسودان لكنه ايضا ليس
بالطريقه الامن تماما حتى يسلكه اي شخص
خصوصا انكم للمره الاولى تشهدون عمليه
نزوح من العاصمه وليس الى العاصمه شكرا لك
يا لينا على مديره مكتب العربيه في
الخرطوم للنايع يعقوب على وجودك معنا
مشاهدينا اعود الى روما وعمليه وصول طائره
تقل رعايه تم اجلائهم من السودان فلنستمع
اذا مشاهدينا تابعت واياكم هذه الصور
المباشره للطائره التي وصلت الى روما
والتي تقل
جده عن طريق البحر الى جده ليش احنا
كمواطنين مثلا من غزه ليش احنا كمواطنين
من غزه موجودين ليش تتعامل معنا بهذه
الاليه الان جبتنا وبتقول لنا انا مش قادر
اعمل لكم اجلاء طب انت مش قادر تعمل لنا
أجلاء طبعا انا طيران حربي عندي فوق هنا
مع استمرار القتال بين طرفي الصراع في
السودان برزت اتهامات لمجموعه الروسيه
بتزويد قوات الدعم السريع بالاسلحه
اتهامات نفتها هذه الاخيره جمله وتفصيلا
في وقت حذرت اطراف اوروبيه من تغلغل روسي
في الساحه السودانيه
كلما اشتعلت نيران المواجهات المسلحه
وبرزت بؤره توتر في اي نقطه من العالم
طفائل السطح الحديث عن مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه الاشتباكات الجاريه في السودان لا
تخرج عن هذه القاعده اتهامات لمجموعه
فاجنر بتزويد قوه الدعم السريع بصواريخ
ارض جو كانت مخزنه في افريقيا الوسطى
للمساعده في قتالها ضد الجيش السوداني
وزير خارجيه فنلندا قال ان ثمه مخاطر من
ان تستفيد مجموعه فاجنر من الازمه الراهنه
على الاتحاد الاوروبي فعل المزيد فيما
يتعلق بالوضع في السودان ليس من العدل ان
يغادر جميع الاجانب البلاد في هذه الظروف
اذا غادرنا فاننا نترك ايضا بعض المجال
لقوات فاجنر وروسيا للاعب في هذه اللعبه
قوات الدعم السريع بقياده حميدتي نفت
الاتهامات جمله وتفصيلا فهي ادعاءه خاليه
من الصحه وجزء من حرب المعلومات والاخبار
المزيفه التي تشن عليها تقول الدعم السريع
نرفض رفضا القاطعا مزاعم تورطنا مع مجموعه
فاجنر في الصراع الحالي في السودان
الازمه في السودان تستمر في التعمق مع
مرور الايام الاحداث على الارض تنذر بتفجر
الوضع اكثر فاكثر مع امكانيه تدخل قوى
خارجيه في الصراع كما حدث في مناطق مختلفه
من العالم فالتاريخ يصر دائما على ان يعيد
نفسه بلال الوجداني العربيه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من جبنائب رئيس جبهه
كفاح السودانيه حذيفه محي الدين استاذ
حذيفه يعني التقارير التي صدرت وصل الى
جنوب السودان اكثر من 10000 لاجئ دخلوا
البلاد في الايام الماضيه هل هناك اي
تحديث حول الارقام ارقام النزوح من الداخل
السوداني الى جنوب السودان
طيبه في الجهه التحيه لكم وافتكر انه
استاذ يعني لا نستطيع سماعك بشكل واضح
بالنسبه انا افتكر انه الزياده وتيره
العنف في السودان
بمتغيرات كثيره على الارض خاصه ما زالت
النزوح هنالك اعداد كبيره جدا وصلت الى
الى مدينه الرنك من الاقادمه من السودان
المواطنين
جنوب سودانيين
وكما توقعنا ايضا انه
لها البعثات الدبلوماسيه من السودان سوف
تنظر باشتعال الحرب بصوره اعنف وبصوره
اكبر يزداد وديرتها بصوره اعلى لذلك انا
افتقد انه الدور الكبير للمجتمع الدولي في
الضغط على الاطراف لوقف هذا العنف
الضغط على الدول كذلك لانه متوقع انه يكون
في ردود افعال لدول اقليميه ومجاوره في
هذا العنف لذلك من المصلحه انه المجتمع
الدولي يضغط على الدول باللا تتدخل في هذا
الشان الداخلي والضغط على الاطراف
بالعوده الى موضوع اللجوء هناك اكثر من
800 الف لاجئ كانت قد استضافتهم السودان
بعد عمليات بعد يعني الصراع كان الذي كان
موجود في جنوب السودان اليوم نحن نشهد
حركه معاكسه من السودان الى جنوب السودان
بحسب الارقام ثلاثه ارباع الوافدين هم من
مواطنين جنوب السودان والبقيه من السودان
ومن دول اخرى
لا وجود للمنظمات الانسانيه هناك من يساعد
هؤلاء
من ولايه النيل الابيض الاعداد الكبيره من
المواطنين جنوب السودان التي وصلت الى الى
الرنك برضو هنالك اوضاع انسانيه بالغه
للتعبيد
هؤلاء النازحين وافتكروا محتاج لمجهود
كبير من المنظمات الدوليه باقاسه هؤلاء
النازحين
والمعالجه مشاكلهم وقضاياهم
وكذلك مجموعات كبيره جدا انخرطت من
الحربي في في الخرطوم ووصلت الى ولايه
النيل الابيض انا افتكر انه المنظمات
الانسانيه عليها لعب دور اكبر في معالج
هذه الاوضاع الانسانيه
البالغه بالتعقيم اصلا يعني جنوبيه
السودان يعاني على مستويات عده ان كان على
مستوى البناء التحتيه وعلى مستوى الخدمات
الاساسيه اليوم مع وصول اعداد جديده من
النازحين هل يعني نتحدث عن اوضاع ماساويه
اكثر الى اي مدى انتم بحاجه للمنظمات
الدوليه التي ليس من الواضح انها تتدخل
الان بخصوصا بان يعني الصراع يتمدد
نعم افتكر انه اول بدايه القائمه هنالك
معسكرات في ولايه النيل الابيض
المواطنين جنوب السودان نزلت من الحرب من
جنوب السودان وفي الفترات الاخيره مع
بدايه الحرب ازدادت اوضاعهم سوءا وانا
افتكر انه المنظمات يعني ما قدرت تلعب
الدور الاساسي في توفير الغذاء والطعام
والامني لهذه
لهؤلاء النازحين فيما اضطر الناجحون
للنزوح العكسي الى دوله جنوب السودان
ولذلك انا افتكر انه الدور المنظمات
الانسانيه والدوليه في اقاسه النازحين مهم
جدا
ليس على جنوب السودان فقط بل في
اطراف الحدوديه للسودان هنالك نزوح كذلك
في في ولايه غرب دارفورد اعداد كبيره برضو
دخلت الى
دوله
في ظروف انسانيه برضو بالغه التعبير وبرضو
قيام تام للنظمات الانسانيه انا افتكر انه
وتيره العنف يعني تزداد يوما بعد يوم
بصوره اسوا ما يلبي بكارثه انسانيه كبيره
جدا في قياس هذه المنظمات الانسانيه وقيام
المنظمات الوطنيه
افتكر انه
المنظمات الوطنيه برضو مغيبه في الحركه ما
عندها اي ممرات
شكرا لك استاذ حذيفه محي الدين حدثتنا من
جنوب السودان
نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا هذه اللقطات
المباشره من جده حيث نترقب وصول دفعه
جديده من الذين تم اجلائهم من السودان اذا
هذه الصور المباشره من هناك فلنتابعها
واعود
اذا مشاهدينا هذه
كانت الصور المباشره
لعمليه انتظار وصول سفينه جديده من
بورتسودان الى جده على متنها رعايه دول
عربيه واجنبيه وهي تاتي بعد وصول دفعات
عده تم اجلائهم طبعا بالتنسيق بين السلطات
السعوديه وبين
الطرفي النزاع في السودان
اذا كما نشاهد بالصوره السفينه يعني شارفت
على الوصول الى الميناء وهي
تقل على متنها عدد من الرعايه الرعايه دول
عربيه واجنبيه كانت قد تم اجلائهم من
العاصمه السودانيه الى ميناء بورتسودان
ومن هناك طبعا بحرا تم نقلهم الى جده
اذا بانتظار وصول للسفينه طبعا كما نتابع
هناك يعني حركه سفن ولكن لا نعلم اي من
هذه السفن هي التي تقل على متنها الرعايه
سنكمل هذه التغطيه واعود طبعا فورا وصول
الرعايه
عشره ايام مرت الصراع مستمر وتداعياته
كارثيه على الاقتصاد السوداني اقتصاد
مهترئ اساسا رغم غنى السودان بالموارد
الطبيعيه كالذهب ومع توقف مطار الخرطوم عن
العمل خسرت الخزينه السودانيه نصف قيمه
صادراتها فيما سعر الصرف انزلق لادنى
مستوياته
عكاز الاقتصاد السوداني هوت فالاخير كان
متكئا على حافه الانهيار حتى قبل بدء صراع
الجنراللين لي الذراع الاقتصاديه تمثل
بخروج مطار الخرطوم عن الخدمه اولا ما
افقد خزينه الدوله اكثر من 50% من صادرات
البلاد اي صادرات الذهب المقدره بملياري
دولار توقف عمل المطار عطل خمسه في المئه
من اجمالي الصادرات والواردات فيما طالت
معدلات التضخم عتبه الستين في المئه ارقام
وصفها مراقبون بغير الدقيقه مضيفين ان
التضخم فوق ذلك بكثير نسبه مماثله قدرت
عند قياس معدل الفقر والذي يتجاوز 60 في
المئه فاكثر من اربعين في المئه من
السودانيين قابيعون في خانه البطاله اما
سعر صرف العمله فتدهور بشكل كبير خلال
الفتره الانتقاليه وايام الصراع الاولى
مسجلا انخفاضا قياسيا امام الدولار ليصل
الى 600 جنيه حاليا هذه الارقام قد تصبح
خجوله اذا ما اتسعت رقعه الصراع الجغرافيه
الضيقه والمنحصره بالخرطوم حاليا ففي حين
توقف مطار الخرطوم الا ان الموانئ لا تزال
تعمل سته عشره ولايه سودانيه لم تتاثر
بالنزاع حتى اللحظه بينها الولايات
الشرقيه مثل الجضارف وكسلا وبورتسودان
وولايه نهر النيل وهي تؤمن الطرق من موقع
الموانئ الى العاصمه
لكن في حال تمددت رقعه الحرب سيتاثر
الاحتياطي المحلي الاجمالي وسيتفاقم
التضخم وتنهار قيمه العمله اكثر واكثر
فخمسه وثمانون في المئه من حجم الصادرات
والواردات الكليه البالغه 15 مليار دولار
سنويا تتم عبر الموانئ البحريه في
بورتسودان والبحر الاحمر فيما العشره في
المئه المتبقيه تشق طريقها الى الجاره
المصريه عبر مينا اي ارجين وشكات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات